welcome to the Keel test ready got the
head off let's do this
the sword of Perseus
son of Zeus the Greek demigod Perseus is
best known for decapitating the Gorgon
Medusa with his mighty sword
the legendary weapon is described as
having a short leaf-shaped blade that
was perfect for cutting slashing and
thrusting
Perseus was given this blade by the
Greek goddess Athena who wanted Medusa
destroyed
later in the myth Perseus used the head
of Medusa to turn the massive Kraken sea
monster to Stone saving the princess
Andromeda
though the story is fiction you can
watch Perseus slay Medusa in the film
Clash of the Titans or visit renowned
artist Benvenuto Cellini's bronze
depiction in Florence Italy I don't want
to see I'll turn into a rock
all right blade Smiths welcome to the
kill test
now in Greek mythology Perseus uses
sword to decapitate Medusa and roof her
head from her body to use it as a weapon
to that end I will take your weapon and
help me to deliver some killing slashes
and blows to liberate her head from her
body Robert you're up first you ready
for this yes sir let's do this going
into testing I am concerned about the
weight I'm hoping my blade can do
everything that Doug wants it to do but
I'm concerned
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
Robert let's talk about your sword here
I like the design that you have of the
Damascus
in there but it's so heavy it's about
five pounds over here but the thing is
it's so forward heavy most of the
weights up here when I'm lifting this I
can feel all the stress right there this
is supposed to be meant to be a
single-handed use weapon now your Edge
is plenty sharp it was easy to thrust
and cut and
it will kill
all right Jared to your turn you ready
sir yes sir let's do this with the
attached you never really know what to
expect and anything can go wrong
[Music]
all right Jared first up you nailed the
balance on this as a one-handed sword
it's about three pounds lighter than
your opponents your Edge is razor sharp
every slash is deep the thrust no issues
at all and most importantly sir
it will kill
all right bladesmith next stop is the
strength Desk release the Jamie Meter
all right bladesmiths we took Medusa's
head during the kill test now the
Krakens Turn to Stone so what I'm going
to do is take your swords and beat them
mercilessly into these Stone cracking
heads it's gonna be brutal
and Rob you're up first how you feeling
a little nervous but I'm ready let's do
it this is the make or break test
thank you
[Music]
you okay yep bounced off the glove
didn't cut me
my blade breaks my heart breaks but I am
just so glad that it didn't hurt Jay
oh a little bit of a problem here Rob
on the Tang you can see a black spot so
it means you had a stress fracture there
with the weight of this sword hitting
those Stone cracking skulls it was
enough to allow that stress fracture to
just continue all the way across so the
good part is that your Edge
held up so good job on the Damascus but
it's kind of hard to swing a sword but a
handle on it
all right
well Robert your blade broke after four
strokes on this crack and head but that
doesn't mean that you're out of the
competition Jared your blade still has
to survive four strikes Jay let's get
crack-a-lackin
this is it right here let's see what it
did to Rob's blade my sword's got to
hold up four swings and I know Jay you
know he's going to try to do some damage
[Music]
[Music]
Jared your blade survived Robert
unfortunately your blade cannot continue
to be tested in this competition and for
that reason I have to ask you to please
leave the forage come on forward my
friend you killed the Medusa though
it's a heartbreaker but I'm really proud
of what I did
Jerry
congratulations the strength of your
weapon has ensured that you are the
forced to fire Champion leaving this
forage with a check for ten thousand
dollars good job brother awesome thank
you
[Applause]
how you feeling right now good how about
a smile or something yeah
all right come on over and Shake our
hands brother good job man good job
I am the new forged and fire Champion
something I never thought I'd say I
can't wait to get home give my daughters
the news and uh take the 10 grand take
my family on a vacation somewhere
foreign
Hanzo a thousand layer katana
[Music]
whoa
born in 16th century Japan hatori Hanzo
also known as Debo Hanzo was perhaps the
most legendary Samurai to ever live
almost 400 years later in the 2003
Tarantino cult classic Kill Bill atori
Hanzo was reimagined as the modern day
bladesmith who creates a katana so fine
it would cut God
in reality the katana is the Majestic
symbol of the ancient warrior Samurai
featuring a simple but elegant
single-edged blade designed for precise
cuts and lightning fast thrusts the
dazzling Damascus layering produces not
only a beautiful piece of Steel but an
incredibly sharp and deadly Cutting Edge
late splits a hanzos katana's first duty
is to kill to find out what kind of
lethal damage your weapon will do I will
take your Katana and deliver killing
blows on this ballistics dummy
all right Mike near up first are you
ready yes sir let's do this
do it
[Music]
yes
Mike your Edge is razor sharp but more
importantly there's bone on your Edge
but your Edge shouldn't roll did not
ship and your blade stayed true
overall sir your blade
will kill thank you
Justin are you ready yes sir let's do
this
foreign
the balance of your blade is very good
it's light it's fast it's easily
maneuverable
but when steel meets the skull there
were some problems
your Blade the serious Bend also on the
edge right here you took some chipping
but overall looking at the dummy I think
your weapon will definitely kill
thank you
gentlemen the second duty of a Hanzo
Katana is that it is to be sharp it is
said that the Hanzo Katana is as sharp
as a thousand razor blades
now sharp blade should cut cleanly
through the Tommy mats a dull blade will
crush Bend or get hung up a dull blade
is not a Hanzo Katana Mike you're up
first you ready for this yes I'm ready
you're blade sir is sharp it cut Pliny
to the thickest of our tatami Matsu but
on the backhand slice it did not cut
completely though overall sir your sword
will cover
thank you Tristan your turn you ready
ready as I'll ever be sir
[Music]
well Tristan your Edge is sharp if you
cut through the tummy mats my concern is
the strength of your blade
it picked up another band now you have
two bends on your blade especially right
here close to the guard
Tristan this Hollywood competition has
been exciting and dramatic you've been
at the epicenter of all of that drama
nobody is questioning the strength of
your character however the strength of
your blade is such that we can no longer
continue to test it
for that reason I have to ask you to
please leave a fortune
Mike you were an Unstoppable force in
this competition and your hatari Hanzo
thousand layer Katana is absolutely
deadly earning you the title of forged
and fire champion and a check for 10
grand good job brother I am forged and
fire champion and it feels awesome
the sick of sword
the sikka is a short but dangerous sword
widely used by Gladiators in ancient
Rome since it was customary to fight
with armor the blade featured a sharp
curve specifically designed to get
around an opponent's Shield a gruesome
killer Warriors would use its lethal
inner Edge to sever limbs or the Blade's
deadly point to hook into the jaw and
Pierce through the head today the sick
is often depicted in popular culture
during graphic Gladiator battles most
notably in the television series
Spartacus blood and Sand
plays with this is a kill test we'll
take your zika sword and deliver killing
blows on this ballistics dummy Frank
you're up first you ready hell yeah
let's do this
[Music]
nice
laughs
well Frank your blade is sharp in combat
the sikka is sometimes used in its curve
to pull away the sword and come in in
this case he pulled away the head
overall your weapon will kill thank you
Tony you ready let's have some fun
all right Tony this is a scary seek a
sword on the initial hack into the chest
cavity it penetrated so deep it totally
demolished this ballistics Love Me
overall sir your weapon will kill
Tony's blade just performs great on this
thing I mean even though they both will
kill it's just look a little bit more
violent so it has me a little uh a
little nervous gentlemen this is the
strength test in order to test the
strength and durability of your blades
I'm going to attack these shields
remember this test is all about what the
shield studio weapons are not what your
weapons do to the shields Frank you're
up first you ready yep let's do this
foreign
your Edge held up perfectly all right
it's still straight it's still Sharp
everything is still tight and solid
well done thank you Tony you're up next
you ready yes
thank you
well Tony
your Edge held up perfectly as well
razor sharp I see no problem with the
Edge from The Shield you know a nice
solid blade well done thank you
all right gentlemen now it's the
sharpness test I'll be cutting through
this sugar cane one cut with the front
edge of your blade one cut with the back
Edge all right Frank you're up first you
ready oh yes
foreign
[Music]
Frank right off your Blade's got a
really nice balance to it you can see on
that first cut it kind of pulled in my
hand but it's still a good feel on the
back cut blew right through any
Gladiator using this be quick be deadly
well done thank you all right Tony
you're up you ready for this yep
[Music]
so Tony is it sharp yes it's very sharp
and it cut very nicely still right still
tight hold on hey
blade Smith's over the course of three
rounds both of you has displayed
excellent bladesmithing talents however
in this Arena of competition there can
only be one champion
Tony congratulations you are the new
forged and fire champion
Frank unfortunately your weapon did not
make the cut please surrender your blade
I'm fine with this result they both
killed but is uh really killed
Tony's already invited me to come up
there and Forge he's going to show me
some stuff I don't know Tony probably
the rest of my life
I mean congratulations you are our new
forged and fire champion and that's a
title that comes with a check for 10
grand good job how do you feel right now
I feel pretty good all right well Tony
please present your weapon to the judges
okay I'm still here it's not a dream and
one it's awesome how do you put it in
words
came I saw in the Concord
he knew
gnomebe noodle was a ceremonial sword
made by the nombe tribe of the
Democratic Republic of the Congo
featuring in the ornate wooden Hilt that
have embellished scythe-shaped blade
this intimidating weapon was repeatedly
used around the late 19th century for
the sacrificial beheading of tribal
slaves the razor sharp outer edge of the
hook was said to separate the victim's
head from his neck in one swift fatal
strike following the abolition of human
sacrifice the nulu transitioned from
Executioner's weapon to an Insignia
Prestige carried at ceremonial dances
bladesmiths this isn't the kill test the
number noodle wasn't just a weapon used
by tribal Chief to show status it was
also known as the beheading sword of the
Congo so to see what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do I will take
your number doodle and I'll deliver
lethal slashes on this ballistics dummy
and though I'm gonna try to take its
head off
we're gonna actually cut the head off of
the stomach
who does that
oh
my God
that was badass all right Paul let's
talk about your number nulu it feels
good in the hand
it's got a Razor's Edge shear that upon
's initial delivery into the gut that
dug in deep all the way into the bowel
now for its intended purpose of going up
to decapitate the head well come on it's
got no head it's dead
your weapon
it will kill thank you all right Stephen
it's your turn you ready yes sir I'm
gonna head on over and grab your sword
I'm a nervous dude and I really hope
that my blade hangs with his
foreign
[Music]
your blade is sharp it lacerated all the
way into the bowels
you can see that cuts through the jaw
and all the whistles ahead
the wood that you have here it's smooth
but it's the index that you have for
that the way you have it flattened out
and avoid that feels good in the hand
and it will kill thanks
gentlemen this is the sharpness test to
test the sharpness of your blades I'll
be cutting into our cane man here
Paul you ready yes
this is what I love to see come back in
the third round this feels like a weapon
It Cuts Like a weapon it went right
through that cane you nailed it thank
you all right Stephen you ready for this
yes sir
foreign
your weapon same weapon different feel
it's a different weight it's a different
balance but the cuts you can see it just
passed right through there wasn't any
resistance on that cane nicely done it's
feels good to have made something that's
effective
gentlemen the test the strength and
durability of your blades I'm going to
chop into these clay pots this is not
about what your blades do to the pots
but what these pots can do to your
blades Paul you're up first
hitting something as hard as a clay pot
I don't have any idea what it's going to
do to my Edge
the balance is really nice on this it's
heavy where it needs to be heavy when
you're swinging it you know where it's
going right there's a slight roll on the
edge of your blade right here that I can
get a fingernail on that everything down
at the handle and the guard are still
tight yeah other than that one roll
seems to have held up well
all right Steve you ready for this yes
sir okay
cool
nice and straight I don't really see
anything out of alignment your Blade's a
little bit heavier than Paul's but it's
got a good feel it's got a good balance
the wood you've got in the handle and
the extension this handle just put the
balance in a really nice place cool dude
I can't feel any deformation on the edge
well done thank you
Paul Steven the judge's deliberation is
complete and they've made their final
decision the forged and fire Champion is
Stephen congratulations you are the
fortune fire champion
Paul unfortunately your weapon did not
make the cut Paul you both made
beautiful weapons and they both
performed beautifully too so then we had
to look at the finest of details and
that rolled Edge and the strength test
well that was his Tiding Factor so
that's why we have to send you home I
understand Paul thank you very much for
turning in such a beautiful weapon but
now I have to ask you to surrender it
and please leave the forge
I certainly accept the judge's decision
my Edge rolled in Stevens didn't first
thing I'm going to do when I get home is
clean my shop and get on with what I
usually make
Stephen congratulations you are the
forged and fire champion and we'll be
receiving a check for 10 grand how do
you feel I feel great it's a little
surreal I damn well approved what I came
here to prove I am creative and that I
can make a functional weapon and not to
be the most experienced if you put your
heart into stuff things you know can
turn out well it was fun as hell and I'm
glad that I came out on top
foreign
weapon that has been wielded by Korean
Warriors since the 6th Century the large
Crescent blade provided the user with
Incredible force that delivered lethal
blows and deep Cuts with one swing into
an opponent historically this heavy
weapon required special skills and was
only wielded in battle by Elite Korean
Warriors today Korean martial artists
who specialized in the Waldo perform
intricate Maneuvers with this
intimidating weapon at festivals and
cultural events
and welcome to the kill test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your weapons will do I will take your
weapons and deliver lethal blows on this
for the six dummy Eric you up first you
ready for this yes sir
all right Eric let's talk about your
Waldo here it is forward heavy there's a
lot of metal in here but it is wieldable
now your Edge is sharp it penetrates
deeply into this blix's dummy cutting
the gel torso into the bones overall sir
you're well though
it will kill thank you all right Dave
your turn sir you ready yes sir let's do
this
foreign
about your Waldo here it is a little bit
heavier than the other weapon heavier
weapons require a lot of adjustments but
your edge here is sharp with this
forward weight that cuts deep into this
malicious dummy and cuts the bones
inside but in doing so sir your Edge
over here did take a little bit of
rolling but the other parts
are fine
and overall sure you're a Waldo
it will kill thank you
all right gentlemen you know what time
it is it's time for the strength test
we're calling this one the bamboo Man
attack
to test the overall construction of your
blade I'm going to take them and gently
tap them they're going to start bamboo
man over here
now remember this is not about what your
weapons do to these targets it's about
what these targets do your weapons Eric
you're up first you ready yes sir all
right
laughs
[Music]
so Eric right off this is a heavy Beast
your balance Point's not bad I kind of
like that right there where you can
manipulate the weapon as far as the
weapon performance goes you maintain an
edge all the way along it's still sharp
nice and done thank you
all right Dave you're up ready yes sir
[Music]
all right Dave
your weapon is really really heavy so
you can make a devastating cut but
recovery is is really slow as far as the
blade
the blade itself is is dented sideways
here
and up above here
but
still solid so you survived quite nicely
well done Dave thank you
blade Smiths this is the sharpness test
the sugar cane slice
to find out how sharp your weapons are
I'm gonna attempt to cut through all
these sugar canes unlike the strength
test this is all about what your weapons
do and how well they cut the sugar canes
are you ready to do this yes sir
[Music]
all right Eric let's talk about your
edge here your Edge it's sharp it cuts
through all the sugar canes and overall
sir your weapon it will cut thank you
Dave it's your turns are you ready for
this yes sir
all right Dave let's talk about your
weapon here
it's still sharp and it cuts cleanly all
the way through but the weight of your
blade as I'm cutting drag downward and I
ran out of sugar cane but overall sorry
your weapon it will cut thank you
well gentlemen you both performed
extremely well in our Korean theme
challenge both through Waldo's did great
during our tests but this is a
competition and there has to be a winner
the judges have made the decision
in today's force and fire Champion is
Eric congratulations
Now Dave you fought hard but
unfortunately you're not today's winner
your time in this competition has ended
and for that reason I'm gonna have to
ask you to please step off the fourth
floor
well Eric you know what that means you
are the newest Fortune fire Champion
you're going to be walking out of here
with a check for ten thousand dollars
congratulations
I feel awesome coming out here winning
the competition having my skills
validated this is a crowning achievement
of mine well done thank you
if somebody wants me to make a wall
dough it's going to cost him 10 grand
the vajra mushti
originating in India the vasha mushti is
an edge knuckle duster the unique design
features sharpened blades on every side
of the handle making it a specialty
weapon only wielded by well-trained
indian warriors the sharp edges on all
sides provided the user with a wide
range of lethal attacks from deadly
stabs and slashes to devastating punches
a traditional Indian martial art where
the weapon is tied to the fists of
wrestlers has lineage dating back to the
Middle Ages and is still practiced today
by professional wrestlers in India using
non-lethal knuckle dusters
blade Smiths welcome to the kill test to
find out what kind of lethal damage your
weapon will do I will take your weapon
to deliver multiple lethal blows on this
ballistics dummy
Kyle York first you ready oh yeah
wow
all right Kyle let's talk about your
weapon here I was worried about the
finger welts that you had there that
they would be an issue especially when
I'm punching no issues there I like the
fact that my acid gets slippery it gave
me a very good grip overall it is a
beautiful piece and your weapon
will kill oh yeah all right Ben your
turn sir are you ready ready let's do
this
foreign
[Music]
here the edges are very sharp but there
are some sharp edges that you have in
here every movement started to give me a
little bruise and cut off some skin
right there but in terms of
what this weapon will do
it will kill thanks Doug my hand
all right please welcome to the strength
test
strength and durability of your vajra
mushties as well as their overall
construction I will be stabbing and
punching into this sheet metal and chain
now you're up first you ready for this
yep
foreign
test your two long blades held up great
the center blade here took some chipping
on that chain I'm looking at the Grain
in there and it's it's pretty big I
would have liked to have seen that
refined but in general these two blades
held up well nice job awesome thanks Ben
all right Ben you're up you ready for
this sure am
foreign
[Music]
well the first thing I feel when I
picked this weapon up is it's sheer Mass
I mean it's a heavy heavy weapon that
did you some justice in the strength
test the only thing I could see is a
little bit of glinting on the lower
blade but the middle blade it took a
pretty major deflection right here it
kind of cracked one more little little
hit here and that would just come off
the main thing working against you on
this blade is the rough inner surface I
couldn't really find a real comfortable
way of getting this finger out of Harm's
Way but after the strength desk is all
in one piece nice job thank you
all right bladesmiths we know your
weapons can heal and we know they are
strong now it's time to find out just
how sharp they are to find out I'll take
your weapons and deliver some stabs and
slices on these spice bags Kylie up
first you ready for this yep let's do
this
[Music]
foreign
let's talk about your weapon it is
comfortable it's a good fit on my hand
it's got a pointy enough tip over there
but with that one piece where you're
missing some edges it was more of a
jagged cut when it came through stabbing
and slashing on both weapons on each end
you'll cut good job thank you Doug
sir you ready ready let's go let's do it
foreign
the weight that you have here back up
the cut because you have very sharp
edges and the cuts are very deep but my
hand when I'm making impact still rubs
on the inside of your handle but other
than that sir your Beast
it will cut thanks Doug
all right guys you guys both came
through with unbelievable pieces of work
unfortunately we can only send one of
you guys home with the title of Fortune
fire champion and a check for ten
thousand dollars and our champion today
is
Kyle congratulations Ben unfortunately
you're not walking home to Champion
today the time has come and have to ask
you to leave the fourth floor all right
thank you guys this was awesome for sure
Cal amazing job I busted my butt and
honestly did the best that I could so I
don't have any regrets
well Kyle congratulations you will be
leaving here with the title Forge and
fire champion and a check for ten
thousand dollars congratulations
my wife's gonna be super pumped when I
tell her that I'm the next Porsche fire
champion
what are you gonna do with that cash man
my wife and I are probably going to use
it for a down payment on a house that's
cool absolutely fantastic 18 months ago
I would have never imagined being here
today hell yeah I'm forged and fire
champion
laughs
the dehome machete
this lethal machete was once wielded by
the legendary all-female Army in Western
Africa known as the dahome Amazons the
long slightly curved blade flared out to
a wide tip giving the female warriors
the ability to deliver fatal blows that
cut cleaning through bone and flesh in a
single blow these skilled women warriors
were an elite fighting force and
extremely intimidating often carrying
trophies of their fallen enemies the
machetes were a powerful weapon designed
to cleave through anything that got in
their way today the dehome machete can
be seen wielded in the 2020 HBO series
Lovecraft country
datefits welcome to the kill test
I will take your machete and deliver
some lethal blows on this ballistics
dummy
Alex you're first you ready for this yes
sir
I'm most concerned about everything with
this test I'm not sure it's sharp enough
I'm not sure it's strong enough I don't
know what it's going to do to my plate I
have no idea
foreign
[Music]
the bounce you have your blade is nice
for every cut I can really control and
seem like I'm chopping in there the edge
no issues at all it is still very sharp
more importantly sir your machete it
will heal thanks
all right Adam it's time to have fun
with your blade are you ready sir yes
sir
I hope my blade doesn't break I had a
lot of setbacks making this blade you
know I had to start over I hope it
doesn't come back to bite me in the buck
saying a little prayer please don't
break please don't break please don't
break
[Music]
all right I'm just talking about your
weapon here this is a very forward heavy
blade but that forward weight really
Cuts deep into this ballistics dummy
overall sir
it will kill
that's worth it right there I go home
now
all right gentlemen you know what time
it is it's time for the strength test
the shield chop
what I want to see on top of how durable
your blades are is their effectiveness
against that Shield all right so Alex
you're up first you ready yes sir
here
all right so Alex obviously there's a
bit of an issue what happened here is
you can you can see the grain size it
looks like 40 grit sandpaper which is
really a really large grain and then
right here
see that black yeah that was a crack
okay so that crack existed probably
during the heat treat once I hit
face onto the shield it just cut loose
Alex we hate to see that your blade had
a catastrophic failure but you are not
out of the fight just yet your blade
broke on the fourth strike so that means
Adam in order to become Fortune fire
Champion you're the homie machete must
survive four strikes you ready yes
everything is riding on these four
strikes I need my machete to hold
together I've got to make it through
this
well Adam you survived your four strikes
that means you are the forge of fire
Champion so congratulations
Alex unfortunately you didn't win this
round you crush it in round one in round
two but your time the forge has ended
I'm gonna have to ask you to please step
off the fourth floor
a little disappointing but I'm
definitely proud of the machete that I
made making something this big was quite
a challenge it's a learning process so
I'm definitely glad I had this
opportunity I'm glad I got to know all
these other Smiths this was fun it was
it was a blast
well Adam your blade survived the four
strikes It's A Beautiful Beast and it
just won you ten thousand dollars in the
title of Forge and fire Champion
congratulations man
well done is it everything you thought
it would be and more it's been an honor
been a pleasure wow what an experience
it's kind of surreal but it's a great
feeling it's awesome my family supported
me so kids we're going to Disney
the Mesopotamian sickle sword
the sickle sword originated in
Mesopotamia at the height of the Bronze
Age around 2500 BC
these sickle and curved shaped swords
often symbolized royalty and power and
were primarily wielded during ceremonies
by Kings and authority figures although
these swords were not common on the
battlefield the belly of the blade
allowed for quick devastating blows and
inspired designs for later weapons such
as the deadly Egyptian kopech
bladesmiths welcome to the kill test
now lethal damage they will do I'm gonna
take your weapons deliver some lethal
blows of this ballistics dummy
they could be up first you ready cut the
head off let's do that
foreign
[Applause]
Jacob let's talk about your sickle sword
right here your Edge is razor sharp
coupled with the fact that this is a
very light weapon I can use velocity to
really wield that sharp edge it cuts
deep into this ballistics dummy and
overall sir your weapon
you'll kill thank you
all right Robert your turn sir you ready
I'm ready all right let's do this
all right Robert let's talk about your
sickle sword it's a very light blade
that much lighter than the other one and
the angle that you have in here lends
itself to use not only velocity but the
sharpness of your Edge to cut very deep
into this ballistics dummy and overall
sir
you will kill thank you
[Music]
played Smiths welcome to the strength
test the armored Warrior chop to test
the strength and overall durability of
your Mesopotamian sickle sword I'm going
to be chopping into these armored
Warriors chicken beer up first you ready
for this I don't think I get a choice
you don't have a choice
foreign
what actually happened is your sword bit
into the other sword by about 3 16 of an
inch and it took out this chip and once
that chip was gone the whole sword blew
up
your grain looks good
but unfortunately it's just this sword
against that sword this time that sword
won yep
all right Jacob we hate to see this
happen you gave us a beautiful blade but
unfortunately it did suffer catastrophic
failure on the seventh strike but you
were not out of the fight yet
because Robert in order to become the
champion you will have to survive every
single one of those seven strikes on the
armored Warrior are you ready let's roll
the dice all right Ben
foreign
good job
well Robert the big thing is it's one
sword nice job thank you
well Robert you made it through all the
testing Jacob it's a beautiful piece of
work unfortunately due to your
catastrophic failure we cannot continue
testing and for that reason I'm gonna
have to ask you to please step off the
forge floor thank you gentlemen it was
an honor thank you very much very nice
job
uh
no it
but I really am proud of the blade I
made either way you know they said
pretty much nothing but good things
about it up until it broke and well I'd
totally come back for this and maybe get
a shot at making it all the way through
Robert we never like to see competitors
blades break but yours did not and that
makes you the newest Fortune fire
Champion you've got yourself a check for
ten thousand dollars congratulations
thanks thanks feel pretty good crazy
dude crazy
in this Championship I think has really
pushed me to my limits and then that
makes me want to push them even more now
I'm a champion I'm going to go ahead and
get my abs Smith membership and just
really refine my skills
[Music]
this is the elephant tusk sword
dating as far back as the 6th Century BC
the mighty elephant was used during
Warfare often armed with the fierce
elephant tusk sword this Lethal Weapon
featured a socket that connected
directly to the elephant's Tusk the
double-edged blade was designed to
inflict massive destruction as an
elephant charged through barricades and
ranks of enemy soldiers throughout
history there is evidence of thousands
of elephant tusk swords being used in
battle however only four pairs of these
intimidating weapons still exist today
blade Smith's welcome to the Keel test
in battle these swords were tattoo
elephants who just rammed across its
opponents find out what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do we're gonna
go Hog Wild on this ballistics dummy
Jaden you're up first you ready for this
hell yeah let's do this
oh
I wasn't expecting his head to come off
all right James talk about your weapon
here
every thrust was deadly it went all the
way through what I do like is I can see
the Damascus pattern on your blade there
Jaden your elephant tusk sword it will
kill
that's all I wanted all right Matt your
turn sir you ready hopefully my store is
not irrelevant after this test
we're gonna have fun
all right Matt it penetrates very deep
and on the way out it cuts it's weighted
weapon right here that when it threw us
see the hole right in the middle of the
ballistics dummy it destroyed everything
in there your weapon right here it will
kill thank you Doug
all right gentlemen the strength test
we've mounted your elephant test swords
on our battering ram here and I will be
attacking that armored Soldier
all right Jaden you ready for this yeah
let's do it okay
[Music]
that's terrifying
Jayden I really have to commend you on
the Artistry of this play the low layer
pattern really pops the connections here
are all really beautifully done
and for this test that tip still has an
edge everything is right and tight and
true and nothing's changed
well done thank you
Matt you ready to roll absolutely okay
[Music]
foreign
held up fine the tip
it's a little bit duller than what it
started out with but I wouldn't run my
finger down this Edge so nicely done it
held up beautifully thank you
all right blade Smith we know your
weapons can kill and we know they are
strong now it's time to find out how
sharp your weapons are this is the
sharpness test the guillotine fruit
slice
I'm gonna take your Allison tusks Sword
release it and try to cut through the
fruit I want to see Clean Cuts all the
way through
get in Europe first you ready oh yeah
all right let's do this
[Music]
nice
all right Jane your edge here cut all
the way through cleanly bottom line sir
your elephant tusk sword you'll look up
all right Matt your turn sir you ready
I'm ready
all right now let's talk about your
weapon here the weight on this it drives
the cut all the way through your Edge is
sharp more importantly sir
you will cut thank you Doug
well Jaden Matt you guys both perform
exceptionally well during your tests but
as you know only one of you guys will be
leaving here with the title of Fortune
fire champion in today's Fortune fire
Champion is
Jaden congratulations you won man Matt
unfortunately that means you did not
come out on top today I'm gonna have to
ask you to please step out
the sword that I've turned in they were
virtually the same performance good job
man yeah you too and Jaden's weapon he
turned in a work of art and I think he
deserves the title
first thing I'm going to do when I get
home kiss my wife and crack open a beer
well Jaden that means you are today's
Forge and fire Champion you're gonna be
leaving here with a check for ten
thousand dollars man congratulations
thank you
I'm the new Sportage and fire champion
and I'm really stoked about it how old
are you again 19 19 years old that is
extremely impressive man thank you what
I'm so bad at emotion
Genghis Khan's sword
one of the most notorious rulers in
history Genghis Khan and his Mongolian
Army conquered the Asian continent
through terrifying land seizures
throughout the 13th century Khan and his
troops used the slightly curved sword to
inflict deep and lethal attacks during
horse raids killing tens of millions of
people in their path
this brutal single-edged blade was
lightweight for sustained mounted combat
while the razor sharp edge easily
decapitated prisoners which was often
the tactic used when seizing new
territory having established the Mongol
Empire one of the largest land Empires
to date Genghis Khan remains one of the
most prolific rulers in history
alright bladesmiths welcome to the kill
test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do I will take your
sword and deliver some killing blows to
this ballistics dummy Peter York first
you ready yes sir let's do this
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Peter first stop your Edge is sharp the
balance feels good but it did take quite
a pronounced Bend but more important
thing is
it'll kill
I timed that perfectly
all right doc Everett are you ready sir
let's do some surgery
[Music]
[Music]
yikes
all right everyone your Edge is very
sharp it slashes nicely your tip
punctures easily cuts on the way out
with all these cuts
it'll kill
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test
now to test the strength and overall
construction of your blades I'll be
attacking our armored targets over here
Peter you're up first you ready
let her rip Tater chip
[Music]
all right Peter um
I'm gonna start with your handle I find
it really comfortable the way it flares
towards the tip works pretty good for my
hand and I love what you did with this
kind of low layer count Damascus it's
very dramatic but
we've got some
very deep roles on this Edge there they
go
here
those chips that's an issue but all in
all a good job
all right Everett you ready I am okay
yeah piece of armor
thanks
all right Everett your blade still spot
on what I really like is the fact that
that blade is
at its widest point maybe 3 16 of an
inch
you don't need weight and mass for
strength in a properly tempered blade
that's really good you've got a section
of Blade here that's not quite as sharp
as it was right there all in all I think
you did a great job awesome
foreign
this is the war batter slice
test the sharpness of your blade I will
take your weapon and slash across these
War banners
Peter you're up first you ready yes sir
let's do this
so where your Edge has a chip because he
catches and rips through the banner
where it's not it cuts nicely overall
sir it will cut
all right ever it's your turn you ready
sir I think this beats the hell out of
peer review all right let's find out
foreign
your edge here does cut it's sharp it
cuts in some of the areas on some parts
of it it ripped but overall sir
it'll cut awesome
all right gentlemen based on what we've
seen in the weapons test the judges have
made their final decision about which of
you is our next forest and fire champion
Peter
your sword took the most damage in our
strength test he had a rolled Edge and
your blade bent for that reason I have
to dismiss you from the forge I may not
be the forged and fire Champion but I
still think I'm a badass myth
well Everett your blade is comfortable
well-balanced strong and deadly and that
makes you the forest and fire champion
and that's a title that comes with a
check for 10 grand good job come on
forward and Shake our hands
this experience was really fun it was
really tough in a lot of places and it's
been a hell of a ride